bonjour à toutes et à tous
alors
pour ceux qui ont pour ceux qui me
découvre avec cette vidéo
je vous conseille vraiment
d'aller voir les précédentes
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter un
peu
d études de cas
taphonomie
préhistoriques sur des sites plie au
pléistocène d'afrique donc pour ceux qui
ont ce qu'ils sont pas familiarisés avec
avec tous les concepts les méthodes un
peu l'historique etc je vous conseille
vraiment d'aller voir
les précédentes vidéos où on aborde tout
ça et qui normalement vous donne le
bagage nécessaire pour comprendre la
suite que je vais vous présenter
maintenant
désole d'ailleurs pour pour la dernière
fois j'étais un peu malade donc je pense
que ça s'entend dans ma voix donc là
j'espère que et j'avais aussi un autre
micro donc là j'espère que tout va bien
que tout le monde s'entend bien et
aujourd'hui donc je vais vous présenter
ces sites là
alors
par où c'est
attendait ok je mets la up
ok donc je vais commencer
le mans ok c'est bon tout marche donc
j'ai commencé tout simplement par vous
présenter le cas très très très
intéressant du site de dickie cas
c'est peut-être
le site le dépôt
le plus ancien sur lequel on peut tire
lait possible de faire de la taphonomie
d'un site archéologique
pourquoi je dis ça parce que le site est
datée à 3,4 millions d'années et c'est
le plus ancien site sur lequel on a
découvert deux potentiels traces de
boucherie
donc bien sûr il est possible de faire
de la taphonomie sur des sites plus
anciens
mais cela va plutôt concerner
la discipline paléontologique plus
cardiologiques dans le sens où
l'archéologie concerne
l'accumulation
d'artefacts et d'objets
reliés
à l'homme aux humains ou la lignée
humaine
sans dessus château dillon disons le
comme ça
donc là c'est la première preuve
potentiel
d'accumulation d'ossements par des
membres de la lignée humaine donc c'est
là où on rentre un peu pour la première
fois tant de la taphonomie
d'ordre archéologiques
alors pourquoi potentiel et pourquoi pas
simplement des traces de deux boucheries
bien sûr parce que je vous présente et
je vais vous présenter une série de
sites dans l'ordre chronologique
actuels qui font débat des sites qui
font actuellement débat dans la
communauté scientifique dans lequel on
n'est pas tous d'accord
donc là je vais vous présenter tic a
alors dit qu'ils
ko en 2010
il y à l'équipe
de max et shannon mcpherron des
collaborateurs qui publient dans la
revue nature
2 ossements
provenant du site de dickie cas le site
digg de dickie cas il n'était pas
nouveau il était déjà connu
il est daté à 3,4 millions d'années et
sur ce site dans cette publication de
max ferro d'accueil et collaborateurs
ils décrivent deux os mans
1-2 dans un de ces ossements et une est
une cote de grand angulaire taille 4
tailles 4 ça va être à peu près 2 lors
d'un
bain d'un élan ou
d'un élan l'antilope africaine pas
l'élan
le cervidé nord américain
dr la taille d'un d'un élan ou d'un
buffle d'afrique
et le deuxième ossements et une portion
diaphyse r2 d'un fémur
d'impôt vite et de taille moyenne
de taille 2 donc ça fait à peu près la
taille d'un d'un springboks ou du gazel
de taille moyenne quoi
et c'est un juvénile
ok donc ça c'est les informations qui
sont dans le papier et sur ses taux
ossements ils décrivent une série de
modifications de la surface osseuse une
série de deux traces linéaire pour la
plupart
que vous pouvez voir ici
qui 2 1
un beau duo une belle paire de 2 ce tri
parallèle
oblique par rapport à lax de los
section
symétrique
eux deux tribunes barque on va pas se le
cacher ça ça ressemble comme ça des
marques de découpe
il y a il n'y a pas que ces deux marques
là sur ce fossile il y a des traces un
peu plus
discrète sur le reste de l'os
et qu'ils ont mené d analyse
microscopique pour essayer d'avoir accès
un peu à
à tout le
spectre
des tmt micro t de la morphologie de la
microbiologie de ses traces
et du coup sûr le deuxième os la
pareille série de deux traces linéaire
pour la plupart donc là c'est un peu
plus chaotique que sur le premier
fossile
un peu plus le bazar mais on observe
quand même la présence de traces
perpendiculaire ou obliques par rapport
à lax de los
les dissymétrique assez clair les traces
sont relativement profonde
voilà donc qui vaquent faire
collaborateurs et publie sa en 2010
pourquoi ça fait débat parce que comme
je voulais dit le site il est daté à 3,4
millions d'années donc 3,4 millions
d'années qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'on est con et dans le
pliocène
on n'est pas encore dans l'ère
quaternaire on n'est pas encore dans le
pléistocène
il faut savoir qu'en 2010 quand ça c'est
publié
les plus anciens restes attribué au
genre humain le genre homo
à cette époque là ils sont datés à
3,8 millions d'années non 3,6 millions
d'années parce que le bleu
de 2,6 millions d'années oui parce que
leurs restes
d'homo de 2,8 millions d'années lui et
date et a été publiée en 2016
donc 2010 plus anciens restes du genre
homo le genre humain 2,6 millions
d'années ok les plus anciens outils en
pierre en 2010
2,6 millions d'années également
donc en 2010 tout était assez cohérent
2,6 millions d'années on à l'entrée dans
le quaternaire l'entrée dans le
pléistocène qui s'accompagne d'une très
très forte d'un très fort événement
d'artifice tarification ça c'est global
1 sur l'ensemble de la planète terre
et en afrique on observe l'apparition
des premiers outils en pierre et des
premiers représentants du genre homo et
quissac pas une des premières traces de
découpe
tout était assez clair ça permettait
un chai assez simple de dire va te vire
6 millions d'années entrer dans le
quaternaire
changements climatiques majeurs qui
s'accompagne de l'apparition du genre
humain dans le registre fossile qui
s'accompagne de l'apparition des
premiers outils en pierre et des
premières traces de consommation de
viande
ça s'articule est plutôt bien
et là 2010
il publie des marques qui sont 600
milles en plus ancienne
que les précédentes qui sont deux fait
600 milles en plus anciennes huit cent
mille ans plus ancien que les que que
les premiers restes du genre humain le
genre humain qui était au départ
associée à cette innovation technique
qu'étaient les outils en pierre et la
consommation de viande
donc là sa demande à changer de
paradigme et ça bien sûr il ya certains
chercheurs qui n'ont pas été tout à fait
d'accord avec ça
donc les preuves pour en faire des
traces de découpe ce qui est dans le
papier de mcpherson et collaborateurs
c'est comme je voulais dit
la présence de deux de ses pairs de
marque
v10 métriques parallèle oblique et
perpendiculaires aux grands axes de l'os
la présence de micros ce tri nations à
l'intérieur même
de la trace
la localisation et l'orientation ses
marques sur les eaux
est également il avance cet argument de
la signature taphonomie qu unique de ses
marques parce que bien sûr ils ont pas
eu pitié que ces deux fossiles là ils
ont étudié
un échantillon représentatif
de l'assemblage provenant du dépôt de
dickie cas et ce qui tisse c'est que
ces traces là elles sont uniques dans
l'assemblage de dickie cas on le
retrouve on les retrouve nulle part
ailleurs
comme je voulais dit certains chercheurs
n'étaient pas d'accord avec ça donc la
même année dominguez rodrigo et
collaborateurs publie une réponse à ce
papier là en avançant des arguments
contraires
pour eux ces marques ont de grandes
chances non pas d'être des marques de
boucherie mais d'être des marques de
piétinement donc dû à l'abrasion tu
sédiments à la surface de l'eau ce créé
par une pression souvent qui est associé
au piétinement de surface
donc quand des grands mammifères
marche à la surface et que vos ossements
sont en cours dans suisse
d'enfouissement et qui sont enfouis en
sub surface et bat cette pression va
pouvoir créer une friction
et créer des marques qui peuvent parfois
est similaire
aux barques de boucherie c'est ce qu'on
appelle et ça je vous renvoie aux
précédentes vidéos c'est ce qu'on
appelle le principe des quiz des cui
finalité voilà c'est le concept qui
postule que deux agents taphonomie qu
différents
sont parfois en mesure de créer des
signatures taphonomie qu équivalente et
inversement deux signatures taphonomie
différentes peuvent potentiellement être
créée par le même agent taphonomie qu ça
c'est bazar c'est un peu tout le le
coeur de la recherche en taxonomie à
l'heure actuelle et
dominguez rodrigo et collaborateurs il
avance également des arguments en faveur
de cette hypothèse alternative qui est
le piétinement
première argument c'est le fait que ces
fossiles ont été retrouvés en surface
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas été
retrouvés in situ dans une coupes
stratigraphiques
après fouille où on retrouve l'ossement
non
cette équipe n'a pas eu besoin de
fouiller pour trouver ces fossiles
ce qui est fréquent d'afrique de l'est
en général parce que contrairement à
l'afrique du sud où nous au travail en
grotte en contexte grotte donc on est
obligés de fouiller pour avoir accès aux
fossiles
eux en afrique de l'est qui travaillent
en général sur des des contextes de
bordure de lacs donc c'est des contextes
et mines sédimentaires de bordure de
lacs ou de systèmes
fluviatile
ce qu'ils paient que eux ils vont
prospecter à l'air libre et essayer de
trouver des fossiles qui sont en surface
et
est en général on trouve énormément
et tous les to toute la difficulté de
l'exercice s'est ensuite est d'essayer
de raccorder ces fossiles de surface qui
proviennent de l'érosion des dépôts
fluviatile
essayer de corréler et de retrouver d'où
proviennent ces fossiles dans les coupes
donc va y avoir des systèmes de collines
qui sont d d d d anciens systèmes
fluviatile en cours d'érosion et ses
faux cils à la surface et on va trouver
ces fossiles et essayer de les raccorder
ou au port aux affleurements des
collines
pour essayer de retrouver d'où ils
viennent ok le fait que ces deux
fossiles proviennent de
deux découvertes de surface c'est pas
anodin parce que ça implique de fait
qui sont été remaniée et qui ont subi
des succès sur deux phénomènes
taphonomie de postes d positionnelle
dont l'érosion
qui
en plus d'être combiné 1 1 une matrice
sédimentaires qui est composée
principalement de sable et de gravier
on peut qu'imaginer que des phénomènes
d'érosion et d'abrasions dans des
milieux sédimentaires à graviers et à
sable fin ça peut bien sûr créer des
frictions
et potentiellement créer des marques
d'abrasion assez assez profond
ça c'est un dessin un des arguments qui
est plutôt basé sur le contexte de
découverte
des fossiles
un des autres arguments c'est le fait
que l'un des fossiles celui ci l'a donc
c'est le bout de fémur basséen juvénile
et ça c'est bazar pour nous parce que
nous en taxonomie en général on a
tendance à exclure de nos analyses les
individus juvénile pourquoi parce qu'en
fait étant donné que leurs os n'est pas
entièrement
informé il va répondre différemment aux
contraintes mécaniques
physiques et chimiques des différents
processus taffonneau milk
et ça malheureusement on est encore en
incapacité
peut-être qu'on le sera toujours en tout
cas à l'heure actuelle on est encore
dans la capacité
de quantifier ce phénomène là de
quantifier
comment
cesser ces ossements réagissent de
manière différentiel selon l'ond au
génie c'est à dire selon le stade de
développement de votre individus
donc s'arranger al on a tendance à les
exclure
bon là ils ont que deux ossements je
peux comprendre que statistiquement
essayé de retirer la moitié de ton
assemblage de thé de ton analyse ça pose
problème donc eux ils l'ont conservée il
en parle c'est normal
mais je peux comprendre que de
l'extérieur ben nous c'est le bazar quoi
parce que comment est ce qu'on peut
prêté ces traces
de manière acte en sachant qu'on n'a pas
encore de référentiels
pour pouvoir pire les appréhender quoi
classés c'est un peu le bazar
autre argument avancé par par
l'équipe espagnole dominguez rodrigo et
et collaborateurs c'est que sur ce même
fossiles on peut bien voir et là on peut
qu'être d'accord avec eux que l'ensemble
du pourtour de la c'est en particulier
cette partie si elle et elle semble un
peu poli vous voyez que les bords ici de
l'os ils sont pas saillants ils sont pas
frais ouais c'est pas un os qui a été
cassée fraîchement
là et on a accès à l'âme
au bord de fractures frais non là ça a
été un peu poli un peu
il ya eu de l'abrasion là dessus ça ne
fait que que supporter l'hypothèse que
ce fossile a subi des processus post et
positionnelle qui ont conduit à cette
signature un peu
abrasive de la surface de l'os et ça ça
ne fait que confirmer que effectivement
il ya eu pas mal de processus post et
positionnelle qui sont en mesure de
créer ces traces linéaire
et en fait et enfin il pointe la
similarité morphologiques entre 7 en
particulier cette marque là qui provient
de d'un des deux fossiles de tickets cas
et cette marque là qui provient d'une
d'une expérimentation 2 piétinement
moderne ils ont recréé ses marques là en
faisant du piétinement en laboratoire et
obtenu cette trace qui effectivement
semble
similaire à une des marques de type i ka
mais mais ce n'est pas fini car une
hotte est qu une autre équipe est rentré
en jeu
même deux équipes je pourrais dire
une éthiopienne et u2
plutôt tanzanienne
qui eux avancent l'hypothèse
non pas d'une trace de boucherie non pas
d'une trace d'eux
le piétinement mais d'une trace de
crocodiles
donc
ce qui est pas mal avec le cas de thika
c'est que ça a permis
plutôt ça a forcé
pas mal de chercheurs en taphonomie à
trouver des alternatives explicative à
ces traces là et ça a permis de
documenter des phénomènes et des
processus était agent qui était encore
très très mal connus dont les crocodiles
un vent dikika la signature taphonomie
des crocodiles pour être honnête elle
était zéro
et là à dikika ça a forcé certains
chercheurs à se dire attends
moi je pense pas que le piétinement ils
puissent créer ce genre de signature la
boucherie oui
beati kikaya du croco eux
alors pourquoi pas les crocodiles étant
donné qu'on les connaît très peu
après perry mentation vous pouvez voir
ici sur les images un peu tout le
spectre
de modification de surface que peuvent
créer
les crocodiles c'est encore assez mal
connu mais il ya beaucoup de de travaux
en cours là dessus il ya moins d'un mois
j'étais en conférence
durant laquelle il y a eu encore des
nouveaux travaux tout frais présentées
sur ces recherches là ou là ils ont même
commencé à corréler la morphologie des
traces avec les comportements des
crocodiles
que certaines traces étaient par exemple
liés à certains comportements
alimentaires des crocodiles par exemple
le
le clip and twist
les crocodiles ont tendance à
faire ça c'est à dire à attraper une
proie en bordure de rivière delà de
points d'eau de l'attirer dans l'eau est
ensuite de twister c'est à dire qui ils
tournent sur eux-mêmes dans l'eau pour
désarticuler et arraché des bouts de de
la carcasse et ça ça va créer des
signatures assez particulière ou en fait
on voit le point d'impact de la dent
d'horloge et ensuite
une bifurcation du duo au twist et à la
dent qui a car ap contre l'os
c'est super intéressant surtout
certaines marques de cet ordre là
qui effectivement peuvent faire penser à
ce qu'on appelle des docks marque c'est
à dire des marques de des groupes qui
sont un peu dans l'entre-deux entre de
la découpe et de la percussion c'est à
dire la découpe assez
percute yves si on peut dire je ne sais
pas si ça se dit mais peu importe
mais bien sûr vous vous en rendez bien
compte là
ça colle pas tout simplement avec les
fossiles de dickie cas si super
intéressant ça n'enlève rien à la
nécessité
de documenter ces traces parce que
maintenant grâce à ces travaux on a pu
démontrer
à 1 2 et de confiance assez élevé que
effectivement dans des sites piopolis
stoessel on a des traces de fossiles des
traces de croco difficile ça très bien
mais ça colle pas avec kiki cas parce
que
vous voyez que les fossiles les fossiles
là ils sont assez peu modifiées même
s'il ya un peu d'abrasion
une paire de marque par ici une paire de
marque par là c'est assez succinct les
crocodiles cédé pour 1 et ils ne vont
jamais
ciblé qu'une partie de l'os en
particulier c'est juste entièrement
random c'est complètement aléatoire ils
vont tout bousiller ils vont tout
éclater
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
préférence ils n'ont pas de comportement
préférentiel
en termes d'alimentation ils vont juste
tout éclater et on va se retrouver avec
des eaux ici là comme ça avec tes
multitude de modifications pas qu'une
seule et là on a assez de surface
osseuse pour démontrer que effectivement
ça colle pas vraiment avec une signature
croco
ok
là je vais passer
on arrive
ah
ça c'est el khadri cas c'est super
intéressant parce que le cas de dickie
cas en fait il nous a permis de nous a
forcés à explorer de nouvelles
alternatives et il est encore au coeur
des débats parce que
il remet un peu
tout le débat donc ça je vous dis je
vous renvoie aussi aux précédentes
vidéos il remet en perspective un peu
tout le débat qu'on a autour de chasse
versus charognards
et toutes les questions des cui finalité
et tout ça donc c'est vraiment un une
étude de cas
parfaite pour illustrer ce qu'est la
taphonomie en ce moment pour le clip
lieu de le plier aux pistes celle
d'afrique
un autre cas que j'affectionne tout
particulièrement c'est celui du cip donc
lui si j'imagine que
vous qui regardez cette vidéo vous en
avez
probablement entendu parler de lui si
la grand mère de l'humanité comme ce
comme c'est comme s'était dit je les
appelais ici de mother of wales et vous
allez comprendre tout de suite pourquoi
donc l'uci je vais pas vous refaire un
peu tout toute l'histoire et tout parce
que sinon ça va durer des heures je peux
on pourrait faire un cours de trois
heures entier sur lucie et là c'est pas
ça le débat nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la taphonomie du squelette de lucy
étonnamment depuis sa découverte en 74
ça date un peu il ya eu énormément d de
2,2 de travaux sur sur un sur lui si
elle a fait couler beaucoup d'encre
notamment sur
l'identification du genre de l'uci ça
c'est un grand débat en
paléoanthropologie en général ce qu est
ce qu on est en mesure de bien
identifier
le sexe biologique pas le genre excusez
moi est ce qu'on est bien
en mesure d'identifier le sexe
biologique d'une espèce éteinte
sa gelée débats au pas les
anthropologues c'est pas la question ici
donc 3,2 millions d'années environ
c'est un peu plus récent que deepika et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
cap hellman et collaborateurs en 2016
puis en 2016 et publiée dans la revue
des tueurs
la première véritable étude systématique
de la taphonomie du squelette de lucy et
ce qui en ressort est extrêmement
intéressant
ils ont identifié sur le squelette
principalement post crânien de l'uci
la présence de trente trois fractures
sur un total de 288 ossements ce qui
fait une fréquence de fractures de 11
points 5 % ce qui n'est pas négligeable
pour un seul individu
s'est fracturé elles sont intéressantes
dans la mesure où en fait il s'agit de
fractures ce qu'on appelle multifocale
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est à dire
que c'est des fractures ici
quittons en plusieurs morceaux
ici par exemple sur la tête humérale on
voit que la tête humérale est toujours
en position vous le voyez ici c'est ce
fossile là
tous les fragments de cette tête
humérale sont toujours
accrochés alors toujours en toujours
chalosse les plus en place à cause d'une
pression qui a apparemment
écrasé cette tête humérale assez
c'est assez facile
à voir en tête ici vous avez une
reconstitution
3d de de quêter l'ubs et russes avant
modification mais nous vendent ou pas
nous
l'équipe de johansson et copains c'est
ayem ils l'ont retrouvé comme ça
et rasé aplatit tu as une pression qui
visiblement est arrivée
par le dessus donne aux quais
c'est ça qu'on appelle une fracture
multifocale c'est à dire à plusieurs
endroits en même temps une pression et
ça éclate à différents endroits d'olonne
il y a également sur le pelvis de l'uci
la présence d'une pointure barque donc
c'est une marque circulaire
il y à là
deux bords de fracture comme ce que
comme comme cela par exemple
qui sont sharp ncri c'est-à-dire
propre
voile est propre c'est pas c'est parce
que c'est pas c'est pas le terme exact
disons qu'ils sont
bien
bien lisse bien net c'est ça bien lisse
et bien-être
et le fait qu'on retrouve
le résultat de deux de ses fractures
multifocale encore en place
c'est à dire toujours accroché à loos
grâce bien sûr à de la matrice
sédimentaires qui s'est consolidée fier
autour
ça laisse penser à ces auteurs
que la fracture a eu lieu
lorsque l'offre n'était plus en mesure
n'était pas n'était pas en mesure de
bouger parce que si la fracture a eu
lieu
lorsque l'ossement était complètement à
l'air libre bah tous les petits morceaux
il se serait et papiers il se serait par
et là c'est pas le cas
donc qu'est ce qui peut expliquer ça
deux phénomènes le premier se serait de
la compression sédimentaires c'est à
dire que
l'ossement et en surface est en surface
ou
ou enfouis dans la matrice sédimentaires
et la pression s'effectue de manière à
ce que l'os se brise mais
soit dans l'incapacité de se déplacer
donc il est bloqué dans la matrice
sédimentaires
et ensuite ça se fossilise de cette
manière là
bas ça implique que l'os
c s'est enfui durant une période de
temps assez assez longue
ils s'étaient articulé il s'est enfui et
c'est
donc on s'attend à ce que la pression
sédimentaires va créer
et
des fractures
sur sec lo sait déjà c'est qu'il est
déjà entièrement
individualisé il se retrouve dans la
matrice il a la pression paf l'os
éclatent aux classes il est déjà bien
sec et la deuxième solution
c'est que cette fracture
se soit produite pendant que l'individu
était encore en vie ou
proche de
sa mort ce qu'on appelle perry mortem
autour de la mort autour de l'événement
du décès de l'individu
pourquoi parce que
si la fracture a lieu lorsque l'individu
est en ville hausser encore dans la
capacité de se mouvoir donc il va rester
de telle manière de de cette façon là
bien sûr si l'individu survie après
s'être fracturé l'os il va
se se remodeler et refusionner et ça ça
se voit c'est bien lorsqu'un hausse a
été
refusé né après fracture en général ils
sont mal fusionner de travers et ses
essais le bazar et en général je pense
que ce sont des individus qui ont assez
souffert par la suite là ce n'est pas le
cas on a aucune indication
que l'os se soient soignés et que
l'individu et et survécu
après de telles fractures donc il ya de
grandes chances que ces fractures là se
soient produites autour de la mort de
l'individu c'est à dire soit c'est la
cause même de la mort de l'individu soit
l'individu est mort
et ensuite pendant que le cadavre le
corps était encore frais et que les eaux
étaient encore dans la chair dans le
corps et dans l'incapacité de vous voir
ils se sont brisées
donc ça c'est l'hypothèse qui est
favorisé par l'équipe de kappel man et
collaborateurs et c'est ce qui est à eux
ils vont utiliser notamment des cas de
médecine légale des cas pathologiques de
population actuelle
oui vous comparez les fractures qu'on
observe sur le sur le corps de lucie
avec des individus
pathologique actuels
qui ont subi une chute
et des fractures résultant de ces chutes
et en particulier ce qu'on appelle les
fractures de compression déry mortem
autour de l'événement de la mort de
l'individu
c'est notamment le cas de certaines
personnes âgées qui parfois
peuvent tomber
et en tombant de cette de cette façon en
avant en essayant de faire blocage avec
leurs mains ou même sans essayer de
faire blocage en tapant l'épaule et la
tête humérale la jonction humérus
scapula
on va se retrouver face à
un ben faut type caractéristiques de
cette chute
quant à ras-bord faux types de fractures
caractéristiques de cette chute qui est
la fracture
en quatre points d'impact sur la tête
humérale c'est la tête humérale qui
suite à cette chute se brise en quatre
morceaux bien distincts et ça ça a un
sens
dans la littérature
médico légal ils ont utilisé ça pour
dire bah c'est paul assez bien à ce
qu'on voit
sur l'humérus de lui si bon je vais pas
bon ben
voilà et
à la suite de ça du coup
ça c'est leur hypothèse primaire et du
coup ils en déduisent que l'uci est
décédé à la suite de la chute d'une
hauteur
suffit aman grande pour
avoir conduit à ces fractures là et à la
mort de l'individu
ait eu du coup étant donné que l'uci est
un australopithèque un barrage les il me
semble que je les ai pas dit mais bon
m'excuserai je pense que vous étiez déjà
au courant donc l'uci australopithèques
australopithecus afarensis étant donné
qu'il y avait encore
un brin date adaptation
locomotrice
aux grappes et
ils ont favorisé l'hypothèse selon
laquelle l'uci est morte à cause de la
chute d'un arbre elle a chuté d'un arbre
suffisamment haut pour
à créer de multiples fractures et en
mourir
avec cette publication ils nous ont donc
fourni cette magnifique reconstitution
qui est assez risible on va pas se le
cacher
je vous laisse regarder
ça c'est l'arbre la chute de l'uci
et ensuite
donc on va le voir un peu plus près on
ralentit pas les pieds tac le bassin est
ensuite claque réception sur la tête
humérale et ensuite on a tous le
descriptif un peu du scénario de ce qui
s'est passé
donc pour eux il ya eu multiples
fractures dues à cette chute a bien sûr
comment est ce qu'ils on peut dire que
c'est un arbre ça peut être une falaise
ça peut être autre chose c'est pas ça
l'important l'important c'est comment
qu'est-ce qui peut qu'elle quel scénario
peut créer cette signature taffonneau
blick ok
donc je vous là je vous le rappelle on a
également sur le pelvis une trace sub
circulaire et eux ils ont émis
l'hypothèse bac du coup elle a été en
fait lors de sa chute vous avez
peut-être pu le voir je vais pas pu
repasser la pub
exactement ici est tombe cheville brisée
en premier
gens qui sont non
jonction
tibia fémur brisé
en deuxième
pareil par la suite c'est la partie
distale du fémur qui se brise et ensuite
intéressant dans leur scénario il
imagine que lors de sa chute
elle a heurté
un objet contondant ou ça peut être une
pierre eux ils pensent que c'est bien
elle a chuté elle a heurté une pierre
sur son bassin
ce qui a créé
cette marque sub circulaire cette
peinture marque ok
tout colle assez bien moi je vous avoue
quand le papier est sorti en 2016
c'était un peu
une private joke avec avec les collègues
c'était un peu un running gag de dire
que l'uci est tombé d'un arbre c'est un
peu ce qu'on pourrait étiqueter de la
paléo poésie c'est à dire
utilisé
des observations taphonomie d'ordre
scientifique pour ont tiré une belle
histoire un peu presque de la fantaisie
moi je vous avoue j'étais assez
sceptique quand
qu'on ce papier est sorti
mais pour être aussi tout à fait honnête
quand il est sorti je n'ai pas lu en
détail
je me suis simplement bloqué à cette
image un peu pâle et au paléo poétique
je me suis un peu
arrêté à leur reconstitution
sauf que allez vous en rendre compte
c'est pas ça l'important
c'est pas le fait qu'elle soit tombée
d'un arbre qui est l'important c'est pas
la reconstitution risible qui est
importante
que le poids de l'argumentaire qu'il est
et donc vous vous en doutez
il y a eu de réponse d'une équipe qui
n'était pas d'accord avec eux et qui a
proposé une hypothèse alternative
selon eux il y a deux possibilités à la
création de ceux de cette signature
taphonomie qu chez lui si ça a été
publié par
il me semble que son prénom c'est
philippe mais je suis pas sûr il semble
que ses filets par philippe charlier et
collaborateurs dans ses collaborateurs
se trouve
non des moindres yves coppens
visiblement
l'équipe d'yves coppens et yves coppens
eu les mêmes vu qu'il est cosignataire
du papier de réponse à kappel mam il
n'est pas d'accord avec cette hypothèse
de la chute d'un arbre eux ils avancent
deux hypothèses alternatives
la première se serait que l'uci ce soit
un moment donné retrouvez
dans
une matrice sédimentaires de type
[Musique]
note slide donc de type un peu
buzz argileuse
liés notamment à des épisodes 2
inondations flottille d'inondation et
que ça a pu bouger le corps bougeait
l'individu et crée de multiples
fractures et notamment créé
faire que le corps se retrouvent heurté
par par des objets contondants des
grosses pierres des petites pierres des
moyennes pierre des arbres des pros
d'aran et c est que ça a pu créer de
multiples fractures
et également l'impact de la pop tu
remarques
et leur seconde hypothèse alternative
c'est celle de l' attaque par un
crocodile
est que l'uci se soit fait manger par un
crocodile à savoir que il me semble de
mémoire
que c'est que dans leurs papiers de
réponse ces deux hypothèses ne sont pas
exclusives selon c'est à dire que l a pu
se retrouver
prise un peu dans la boue dans de l'eau
épisodes d'inondations et ensuite manger
ou linverse qu'elle se soit retrouvé
choper par un crocodile manger et c'est
un peu éparpillé éboulements suite et se
retrouve
chez dans tous les sens par des épisodes
d'inondations et c'est
pour eux il y a
trois grands arguments qui permettrait
de
de confirmer ces hypothèses
la première c'est qu'il n'y a pas selon
eux qu'une seule trace sur sub
circulaire sur le pen fils
de celui ci mais il y en aurait 2 il y
aurait celui ci
ces essais donc ça c'est la trace sub
circulaire qui a été observé enregistré
est décrite par qu'apple bad et
collaborent et charlier collaborateurs
ils disent ah ouais mais il y en a une
autre sur le prime sur pelvis et c'est
ici et c'est celle ci
ou pour eux étant donné qu'il y en a
deux
noeuds ce ne serait pas due à
un simple et unique choc
du tube elvis contre une roche mais bien
la pression de deux canines d'un
carnivore qui aurait créé un double
mark suppes circulait
ont pour eux ça pourrait être plutôt
carnivore est plutôt crocodile alors
franchement pourquoi crocodile est pas
et patti gras dents de sabre félins en
général y aident qu'un canidés genre
licka ans chacun et c'est pourquoi
crocodile en particulier il n'explique
pas vraiment
ensuite second argument c'est que l'uci
le squelette de lucy à lui étaient
découverts sur une distance de 50 à 100
m
ça ne se passe pas un cadavre qui a été
découvert il situe en place en
articulation s'était découvert sur 50 à
100 mètres en surface une surface
exactement comme comme les les restes du
tic à vous pour eux ça ça va avec
avait dario
d'un mode slide la flo digue qui a
dispersé les restes
et enfin
troisième argument majeur c'est la
présence de crocodiles dans l'assemblage
du même niveau que l'uci dans le même
niveau que lui s'il ya
des crocos
ok
sauf que
il y a eu les pousses de kappel man et
collaborateurs pour dire non non non
elle est bien décédé d'une chute
en tout cas c'est l'hypothèse la plus
parcimonieuse pourquoi es tu là
pour être honnête je pense qu'ils ont un
peu
détruit l'équipe de charlier et coppens
même si moi à la publication en 2016 de
la ta faute du si j'étais plutôt du bord
de charlie et copains ça
là j'avoue que
ils les ont un peu détruit proprement à
la manière scientifique comme en bas
d'une part en démontrant que la seconde
traces de carnivores observé par charlie
et collaborateurs et bien en fait c'est
un foramen douris y ait
un foramen nourricier pour ceux qui ne
le savent pas c'est ce sont des décades
au
naturel anatomique qu'on retrouve à la
surface des eaux
et sa bouille on assume plein partout
sur les ou quoi
tout l'avc tu es de bien connaître son
anatomie pour faire de la bonne teinte
onomie parce qu'il ne faut absolument
pas
confondre
des
caractéristiques anatomiques
les confondre comme des modifications
tinfos nomique parce que là toutes nos
interprétations sont faux c'est à cause
de ça et là c'est exactement ce qu'ils
ont fait ce qui est étonnant de la part
de philippe charlier qui est médecin
légiste
et d'yves coppens qui est pâle et
anthropologue spécialiste de la natalité
des hominidés peuple i hope liste
hossein donc un peu étonnant de leur
part ils ont confondu
leurs traces ils ont confondu un fort
ahmed nourricier pour une trace de
carnivores et comment démontrer sa basse
est assez simple ils ont pris qu'apple
ma des collaborateurs une photo
du pelvis de l'uci et ils ont comparé à
des pelles vi bat d'autres primates homo
sapiens ici chimpanzé est
systématiquement au même endroit autant
le pelvis on a une série de faux remède
nourricier
systématiquement au même endroit c'est
comme ça
c'est l'anatomie
sauf que malheureusement philippe
charrier collaborateurs ont fait de la
taphonomie ur des ch'ti scadd que des
observations en tomographie
et ch'ti scadd de très très très
mauvaise qualité de très très faible
résolution ce qui les a conduit à
confondre un fort ahmed avec une trace
carnivores
sa
première chose donc il n'y a bien qu'une
seule trace sub circulaire taf d'ordre
taphonomie qu'à la surface du pelvis
de l'uci et il n'y a pas de trace de
carnivores sur tous les autres sauts du
squelette de lucy il n'y a qu'un seul
essai sur le pelvis
ensuite pour aller à l'encontre du
scénario mode slide flooding c'est tout
bête
la matrice sédimentaires dans laquelle a
été découvert lui si le contexte
sédimentaires
de lui si c'est pas du tout un
environnement de mode stone
c'est pas du tout du style argileux et
c'est un nom c'est un environnement
sableux
de type
vous savez ces rivières africaine de
très forte at à très faible débit pardon
ces lits de rivières à c'est assez calme
qui vont déposer tout simplement 7
cette matrice sédimentaires d'ordre
sableuse là on n'est pas du tout sûr un
contexte de
de blood stone et ça encore une fois
il coppens yves coppens ils auraient dû
le savoir est ce que bah il a quand même
heure
était sur le terrain quoi donc bon
et ensuite
bah tout simplement ils ont également
utilisé la carte de la taf au delà de la
signature taphonomie qu unique un peu
comme mcpherson et collaborateur
scientifique à en disant que bas
des eaux mais il n'y a pas de trace de
carnivores ailleurs sur le squelette de
lucy et il n'y a pas
de signature taphonomie qu équivalente à
l'uci sur le reste de l'assemblage
ou ce qui a été découvert dans ce niveau
voilà ces deux signatures taphonomie
cassé unique qui demande une explication
différente
donc voilà et je vous avoue que quand
moi j'ai préparé ce cours il ya
plusieurs mois
quand je et ce court j'ai décidé de
prendre l'exemple de l'uci dans ce coup
et du coup ça m'a forcé à re lire en
détail ces trois articles l'original la
réponse est la réponse de la réponse
est je vous avoue que qu'apple ma des
collaborateurs m'ont fait changer d'avis
grâce à leurs arguments je vous avoue
que face aux aux preuves taphonomie
qu'ils avancent
effectivement
le scénario de la chute de l'uci à
partir d'une hauteur
à ses hôtes c'est unique c'est un
scénario assez parcimonieux pour
expliquer la signature taphonomie qu de
l'uci et pour le moment on n'a pas
encore trouvé
d'hypothèses alternatif meilleur que ça
pour expliquer l'entièreté de la la la
signature taphonomie de l'uci
en prenant à la fois en compte son
contexte sédimentaires archéologiques et
phonique donc ils vont assez convaincus
à ce sujet là et ça m'a fait changer
d'avis ça change pas que la
reconstitution de l'uci qui tombe de
sonars et me fait toujours rire mais
voilà
c'est ça la science il faut pas avoir
peur de changer d'avis ils m'ont fait
changer d'avis sur le cas de lucie
voilà
ah oui et pour roma est ce que j'ai
besoin de le dire mais pour le cas du de
l'attak par les crocodiles là
l'hypothèse alternative de charlier et
coppens vous en rendez bien compte que
ça colle pas du tout parce que encore
une fois la tafna belle à la signature
taphonomie des crocos et colle pas du
tout
signature dafoe de lucie qu absolument
pas
on avance un peu dans le temps on va
parler
maintenant de
ça fait combien de temps que je peux on
va les maintenant 2 on va partir en
afrique du sud et on va parler de ce
terreau fontaine
et de l'origine du cannibalisme
alors
ce terreau fontaine
est une grotte découverte en afrique du
sud qui est extrêmement importante dans
l'histoire de de la paléoanthropologie
et de la paléoanthropologie en afrique
du sud en particulier
et pour la paléoanthropologie en général
parce que
pour vous refaire un bref historique
1924 il ya la découverte
du premier fossile
d'australopithèques au monde par raymond
paré monde art donc c'est c'est le sait
le crac de l'enfant de tang
australopithecus africanus qui a permis
par la suite de démontrer que
que darwin avait raison
dans son ouvrage
pas l'origine des espèces mais
de thyssen hoffman je me souviens plus
de plats du titre en français
donc dans c'est tout j'la darwin il
postule ils avancent l'hypothèse selon
laquelle
l'origine de l'homme de l'homme
devraient se retrouver en afrique parce
que il y à un concept est un phénomène
paléontologique assez universel qui veut
que
l'origine d'un faux si l'origine d'un
taxe on se
retrouve en général tant une zone
géographique dans laquelle on trouve à
l'heure actuelle ses plus proches
parents
nous non plus proche parent vous le
savez c'est les chimpanzés les bonobos
on les retrouve en afrique équatoriale
et c'est ce qui a conduit darwin à
émettre cette hypothèse là de dire
l'origine de l'homme devraient se
retrouver
en afrique et sauf que à l'époque darwin
il n'y avait pas encore de preuves
paléontologique pour étayer cette
hypothèse 6 924 et
découvertes 1925 description
du premier grade d'australopithèques au
monde par raymond arthur d'arte bien sûr
le monde n'était pas prêt pour ça parce
qu'à l'époque
de l'origine de l'homme était situé soit
en europe soit en asie en asie par les
découvertes par eugène dubois
des premiers restes d'homo erectus
et en europe par la découverte première
de néandertal puis tu ailles de la
période 6 mais également de l'homme de
piltdown en angleterre qui se retrouve
par la suite être un faux
c'était un faux c'était un crade
mais ça c'était un crâne
d'un tintin d'homo sapiens provenant
tu ne sais plus tueur evans qui a été
recollée associés et ils ont plutôt avec
une mandibule toronto ce qui lui donnait
7 à d'atholville xts mosaïque mosaïque
de caractère primitif et moderne assez
grossier bien sûr
mais voilà du coup ça ça a été prouvé
dans les années 50 ou 60 il me semble ça
a été prouvé que que ce crâne était un
faux grâce à l'invention
de la datation par carbone 14
grâce à l'invention
du carbone 14 ils ont démontré que
effectivement l'homme de piltdown était
d'infos et ce qui a permis
progressivement à faire de l'afrique
effectivement le berceau de l'humanité
le problème c'est que à cette époque là
bas donc raymonde art il se baladait
avec son enfant de deux temps que child
le premier craint de se répéter que ce
africanus mais ben c'est un juvénile née
du coup ça ça a conduit certains
paléontologues africain a essayé de
rechercher les premiers spécimens
adultes d'australopithèques bon j'avais
dit que je serai prêt sur l'historique
donc en gros ça a conduit un autre
paléontologues robert ben robert broom a
exploré des nouveaux sites à la
recherche du premier grade adultes
d'australopithèques ce qui permettrait
d'être le dernier coup de marteau pour
dire effectivement
l'origine de l'humanité si gyan en
afrique
et il a réussi sur le site de staercke
fontaine elle a trouvé le premier crade
adultes
d'australopithèques sts 5006 place
ils ont continué les fouilles asder
pantel plein de dépôt plein de faux cils
en particulier d'homidide
impressionnant et en 76 et découvert le
crâne sdw 53 c'est celui que vous voyez
ici donc là vous voyez exactement le
même grade
avec deux reconstitutions différente
parce qu'il a été retrouvé en morceaux
et ils sont pas sûrs d'eux les
paléoanthropologues sont pas d'accord 2
comment les réarranger
en sachant que certains pensent que st
w53 était un australopithèque
c'est celui de gauche et d'autres disent
non c'était probablement un premier
représentant du genre homo et là c'est
plutôt la reconstitution de droite donc
selon comment on reconstruit ce fossile
on va se retrouver avec une
identification spécifique différent tu
vois ça c'est pas nouveau c'est le bazar
parce que ba australopithèque et
premiers représentants du genre homo
c'est le bazar australopithèques est un
est intact son paraphe il éthique donc
ça veut dire qu'ils
qu'il englobe
différents taxo qui qui ne sont pas
qu'ils ne partagent pas
un seul et même unique en s'être commun
c'est à dire que ça ne regroupe pas
l'entièreté de leur de leurs clad donc
voilà bref c'est le bazar
bref 76 il découvre ce crâne nous ici
notre question c'est pas de savoir si sa
nostra le pit est qu un propre premiers
représentants du genre homo nous ce qui
nous intéresse vous le savez c'est la
taphonomie de ce cra delà
en 2000
travis pickering écoles et
collaborateurs trois américains travis
piquerez ict hausse et tim white publie
la taphonomie de ce crade et en
particulier l'observation de trois
groupes de marque linéaire à la surface
de l'eau zygomatiques du crâne
et
c'est rare à elles sont localisées à
l'intérieur de l'os zygomatique
parallèle
su parallèle
oblique tison à lax de los une
morphologie qui selon eux est plutôt
enlevé dissymétrique avec des mérous des
micros ce tri nations à l'intérieur des
marques et ensuite
également encore une fois
l'argument de l'absence
de marque similaire sur les autres
fossiles de l'assemblage et d'une tente
une signature taphonomie qu'un smic
alors moi il ya maintenant plusieurs
années quand j'étais en master j'ai eu
comme comme sujet d'étude sujet de
recherche de réévaluer cette hypothèse
sur
la taphonomie tu craques de rester w53
parce que
wade
seul re
des traces là étaient des trains de
boucherie
selon eux le fait qu' on retrouve des
traces en v dissymétrique avec micro ce
tri-nations oblique par rapport à lax de
los
tueur 7 cet élément ou ceux en
particulier
l'oci comme atik à l'intérieur qui
correspond à l'insertion du muscle
master qui permet la mastication
pour eux c'était des preuves tangibles
pour dire qu'il s'agissait de traces de
boucherie sur ce crâne
la volonté de tout simplement coupé
l'insertion du muscle masse et terre
pour pouvoir désarticulé la mandibule et
pouvoir accéder à la langue et ensuite
également à la boîte crânienne au
cerveau parce que ça c'est aussi des
mets qui soit assez recherchée
donc
ils ont avancé cette hypothèse marque de
boucherie probablement lié à la pratique
d'un cannibalisme d'un cannibalisme
alimentaire ou rituelles
attention là on parle d'un crade peu
importe s'il s'agissait
d'australopithèques tu premiers
représentants du genre homo ce cra delà
et estimé avoir environ 2,6 millions
d'années
au plus récent on estime qu'il a
minimum 1,6 million d'années donc entre
1,6 et 2,6 millions d'années c'est super
vieux c'est beaucoup plus vieux que les
premières preuves
défini yves de la pratique du
cannibalisme qui dans mes souvenirs ont
six cent mille ans
600 1000 en c les traces condat sur les
spécimens
espagnol
d'un cannibalisme systématique
et là
ils nous sortent un peu sans pression
que le cannibalisme pourraient être
potentiellement
800 mille ans plus vieux
qu'estimé auparavant au minimum et
potentiellement 2 millions quasiment 8
nous deux millions d'années plus vieux
qu'estimé auparavant
c'est énorme donc moi mon sujet de
recherche s'étaient de réévaluer cette
hypothèse
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a repris des
photos de meilleure qualité soit un peu
tous les angles
un peu plus qualitative
on a un peu observé ces traces là on a
ensuite recréer des marques en
laboratoire lien du piétinement et à de
la boucherie pour ensuite comparer les
différentes
morphologies de ses marques et on a fait
aussi également un peu de travaux de
recherche sur le contexte de découverte
de ce fossile là et on a trouvé pas des
photos assez parlante de la découverte
ou ici on à la découverte du donc du
crad vous voyez ici la bordure de la
calotte crânienne
ici là
le morceau un peu plus épais
il correspond à l'os occipital
parce que là crâne il faut imaginer
qu'il est retourné et qu'on le découvre
du dessous donc ici ce que vous voyez
ici
c'est la bordure de la calotte crânienne
ici l'épaisseur de l'os occipital et
devant ici là vous avez le maxillaire
hockey
et la pam poum un bloc de chair tu donc
c
ce la même famille que les silex on
retrouve énormément dans les crottes en
afrique du sud
et là on retrouve de nombreux blocs ici
là là là tout autour du crad qui
potentiellement avec la nature du dépôt
et avec la compression sédimentaires
peuvent créer des traces d'abrasion
surface des eaux c'est
presque attendu
donc pour nous le fait qu'on ait réussi
à démontrer que que là d'un point de vue
morphologique ces traces ne collait pas
vraiment à des traces de boucherie mais
était plutôt similaires à des traces
d'abrasion naturel de type bâtiment ou
de type pression sédimentaires que ça
colle au contexte de découverte du
fossile et au contexte
paléontologique et archéologique globale
de la région
bon
on a pu et ses résultats en 2018 en
disant
qu'il faut garder toujours en tête
l'hypothèse la plus parcimonieuse
en faisant appel au concept du rasoir
d'occam
c'est à dire que l'hypothèse la plus
simple est toujours la meilleure c'est
le principe de parcimonie
donc pour nous l'hypothèse la plus
simple c'est l'hypothèse d'une
du tout une abrasion d'ordre naturel et
pas du tout d'un vieillissement du
cannibalisme de 2,2 de plus d'un million
d'années quoi
je vais passer sur sur celui ci parce
qu'il est il est peut-être un peu
papa très intéressant pour vous
je vais plutôt vous parler
et avancer dans le temps
et vous parlez un peu plus du site de
coopers
concrètement on va dire la même chose
que sur que sur soi 30 donc bon
donc
cooper
cooper c'est un site qui est assez
intéressant donc sept sites que j'ai
étudié pour ma thèse de doctorat c'est
un site qui est datée entre 1 4 et 1
million d'années et ce site il a été
découvert en 1938 donc ça fait longtemps
par un professeur d'anatomie
middleton show qui a découvert une temps
dominique fossiles sur la ferme sur la
propriété
de monsieur cooper
ceux ci la suite été fouillés
notamment par charles brain ça je vous
renvoie encore aux vidéos précédentes si
vous avez envie d'en apprendre un peu
plus sur le personnage
hochart le brave charlypop brain a
fouillé coopers il n'a malheureusement
pas trouvé plus de
dominique fossile donc il a arrêté les
fouilles
ça c'était en 58 il me semble
sa thèse
est le site donc le site et à ses petits
seins et il n'a pas fait l'objet de plus
de recherche que ça il a fallu attendre
la fin tout fin des années 90 début des
années 2000
pour que l'iburger et christine staniec
heures
deux chercheurs américains basés en
afrique du sud s'y intéresse de nouveau
en 2001 ils vont entreprendre des
fouilles systématiques
alors c'était 54 pardon
les flux papa 58 et footeux pareil donc
ils vont reprendre les fouilles
christine styger est libéré coeur en
2001 des fouilles systématiques donc
fouille systématique c'est à dire
plusieurs saisons de fouilles parents ou
en moins une au moins une saison de
fouilles par an tous les ans
qu'ils ont fait ça de 2001 jusqu'à 2009
donc il ya eu huit ans de fouilles et au
moins huit saisons de vous
ça a permis la découverte
de nombreux restes
de grands vertébrés mammifères mais
également la découverte de nouveaux
fossiles d'hominidés
tu y ressemble à ça c'est assez commun
en afrique du sud c'est en fait ce qui
reste une ancienne chambre deux grottes
la grotte n'existent plus parce que en
afrique du sud pas les plateau karstique
qui faisait
office de réceptacle aux grottes dans
lesquelles se sont formés les dépôts
fossiles ils se sont tellement érodé que
maintenant dames on marche à l'air libre
dans ce qui était avant des grottes
c'était le cas pour cooper donc ça c'est
ce qui reste de d'une ancienne chambre
de la grotte dans lequel ces fossilisés
les dépôts sédimentaires
ces fouilles
elles ont permis la découverte de plus
de 50000 restes de plus de 50000
fossiles
ton state reste de parents trope donc
qui est un d'hominidés fossiles
paranthropus robustus
contemporain des premiers représentants
du du genre humain et un restes
d'hominidés indéterminée 49 outils
lithiques également et le site il est
daté entre 24 et un million d'années ça
je vous dédie
petite anecdote marre ici vous avez
une un fragment démis mandibules de mes
gants theron meggan theron c'est une
espèce
de tigre à dents de sabre est un s'était
délecté du cadre ça plutôt de petite à
moyenne taille c'est pas des gros tino
feliz
les gros mots terium plutôt parce que
dino fait son défaut tigre à dents de
sabre
d'un point de vue anatomique c'est pas
les gros mots terium un peu vénère lassé
des petits
des petits tigres à dents de sabre qui
faisait plutôt la taille non pas d'un
gros lyon mais plutôt d'un petit léopard
ou d'un guépard
caracal dans caracal si je pense
je suis pas expert des carnivores donc
donc là vous avez 7 monticule là à
savoir que ici vous avez l'avant ici
vous avez les alvéoles pour les kadid
hockey ici le dire thème le diastème
tous les primates là on n'a pas de
diastème toutes nos dents
s'enchaînent c'est pas le cas chez
beaucoup de grands mammifères
chez les carnivores j'ai beaucoup de
recul et
d'être
tous ouais tous vous avez un diastème
c'est à dire c'est
l'espace que vous avez là entre les
canines
et les dangers galles c'est à dire
prémolaires volèrent vous avez un espace
entre les deux édenté c'est normal c'est
le geste est donc ici vous avez les
candides donc incisive qu'elle alvéoles
pour la canine est ici la levée hall
pour
l'après molères
et voilà
et
en fait ça peut porter à confusion on
peut imaginer que celle inverse que ici
ça va être en fait le début de la
branche mandibulaire et que l'avant de
la mandibule se trouve ici ce ce
phénomène y seul il est créé en fait par
le fait qu' ici
chez b en période c'est une signature à
ses caractéristiques de mes gants
période vous avez le développement ici
d'une protubérance mentonnière elle est
fracturée ici et vous imaginez bien peu
le tracé que ça devait avoir ici une
protubérance menton mentonnière ici
voilà mais ici c'est bien l'avant
de la mandibule les alvéoles pour les
dents et ici vous avez
foramen nourrit fin le foram nettement
antonio sont
pas sûrs du terme en français
et moi pendant ma thèse mon travail ça a
été de faire
d'étudier l'entièreté de l'assemblage de
grands mammifères d'un point de vue à la
fois taxinomique c'est-à-dire identifiés
des spécimens faire un peu de la
paléontologie
classique de l'assemblage
ensuite une approche paléo écologique
c'est à dire utiliser cet assemblage
pour essayer d'en d'en comprendre le
paléoenvironnement
une approche ensuite taffonneau mik
c'est à dire comprendre comment s'est
accumulée cet assemblage
même si le site est petit il est
extrêmement riche et on s'est vite rendu
compte de l'incroyable diversité de
l'assemblage on a six ordre différent au
moins 12 familles de grands mammifères
je vous parle que des grands mâts
différents donc je vous parle même pas
de deux des micromammifères de type
rongeurs et de tout ce qui est dans ma
vie faire c'est-à-dire
rbe est d tout ce qui est les arts
reptiles et
les oiseaux
aves on en a eu
beaucoup
moi j'ai étudié 21000 fossiles pour
cette thèse ça a été
quasiment là
l'intégralité de l'assemblage de grands
mammifères 21000 reste
6h12 famille 37 genre 37 j'aurai 32
espèces
la majorité de l'assemblage et complots
et composé par les peaux vite et bien
sûr c'est les ongulés les plus
représentés selemani faire des plus
représentés les grands mammifères les
plus représentés parce que ils sont
abondants dans la nature et qui sont des
proies préférentiels pour les carnivores
mon étude taphonomie qu'elle a
directement commencer par essayer de
voir s'il n'y avait pas un billet
taffonneau milk dans la représentation
même des éléments squelettiques et
effectivement quand on étudie par classe
de taille donc
petit pot un bovidé grand bovidés la
corrélation entre
la fréquence
de représentation des éléments
squelettiques
envers la
densité de ces éléments on remarque une
corrélation systématique et
statistiquement
positive et significative
donc entre représentations squelettiques
et
la densité minérale osseuse qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que en
d'autres termes
à cooper les éléments les plus
représentés dans l'assemblage sont ceux
qui sont les plus denses
et les éléments les plus fragiles sont
les moins représentées ce qui veut dire
condat terre rt
processus taphonomie qui sont à
l'origine de ce pied de représentativité
donc ça c'est qu'il faut qu'on le garde
à l'esprit lors de notre approche
taphonomie quai lors de nos
interprétations que notre assemblage est
biaisé
il est biaisé dans le sens où
la plupart des fossiles les plus
fragiles ne sont pas représentés un
coupeur
et ça ça se ressent très bien dans les
profils de mortalité donc quand on
étudie les profits de mortalité des
bovidés de coopers donc c'est à dire la
démographie ben on remarque qu'on a une
prédominance des individus adultes on a
une très très bonne représentation des
individus juvénile ce qui est
extrêmement intéressant mais
c'est sûrement
pas du tout représentatif de ce qui
était l'assemblage à l'origine parce que
comme je voulais dire on a un biais
taphonomie de claire
et les ossements des individus juvénile
sont beaucoup plus fragiles que les
individus adultes et le fait qu'on ait
observé
ce biais taphonomie qu alors à
l'encontre de la préservation
des restes les plus fragiles ça pourrait
expliquer une sous-représentation des
individus juvénile ici tout simplement
en termes de motos de modification de
surface
ont donc f que
les modifications de surfaces les plus
représentés sont celles qui sont
attribués à l'action des carnivores
5% des restes que j'ai étudié porte des
traces de carnivores
sous la forme
de traces de dents de kalin ici par
exemple
perforation par canine ici donc ce n'est
pas une perforation mais c'est un qq1
cupules d'écrasement
par une tante carnivores également
perforation ici
double perforation par deux canines ici
et là on a également deux pulls
d'écrasement mais comme vous pouvez le
voir elles sont légèrement différentes
de celles ci pourquoi parce qu'elles ne
sont pas super circulaire mais plutôt
ovoïde
avec une une section
en leur centre ici
qui fait presque symétrie
et ça en général c'est plutôt lié à
l'utilisation des dangers galles en
particulier et carnassière c'est à dire
des temps c'est quand des carnivores qui
sont utilisés pour
découper la viande
et c'est plutôt ça qui va créer ces
traces de dents de cette morphologie là
alors que les morphologies circulaires
sont plutôt créé par les canines qui
sont des danses circulaire
et on a également un peu toute la
séquence de digestion qui représentait
un coupeur donc voilà cdo qui sont
avalés en général par les hyènes qui
sont digérés par les sucs digestifs et
qui sont ensuite récurent jt et ça on le
retrouve à cooper assez clairement
lorsqu'on étudie
la distribution des dimensions
des traces de dents de carnivore à
cooper ça se fait assez simplement on a
ici nos traces de dents et ben moi je
vais mesurer à l'aide d'un microscope
calibré
la longueur maximale et la largeur
maximale de chaque
trace de dante carnivores sur chaque
ossements
ça ça me permet ensuite de faire un beau
nuage de points en xy on a très
simplement ben voilà en mm lauga maximum
largeur maximum
toutes les données issues de coopers
sont les points bleus et des points
oranges sont des données actuelles
récupérés
sur des eaux qui ont été mangés par
différents carnivores moderne
avec ici les bars qui sont les écarts
types
95%
d'intervalle de confiance qu'est
et ça nous permet
tout simplement d'observer que honda
une diversité assez
importante
de carnivore à cooper on a des dents on
a des traces de dents de carnivore à
coopers qui sont
extrêmement petit en taille quiros qui
sont similaires
à ce que peuvent produire des canidés
sauvage africains actuels mais c'est à
dire plutôt les chacals et les lycans
honda également
des traces de dents su des spécimens de
coopers
qui sont plutôt liées à l'activité de
carnivores de taille moyenne donc plus
tôt et par léopard
et sûrement
petites espèces de félidés éteinte
et ensuite on a
des traces de dents de carnivores
exceptionnellement grande
à cooper ce qu'ils vont elles plutôt
être attribuée à l'action des yens et
des grands félidés donc lions et tigres
à dents de sabre
dino fedis homo terium mais quand et
gijon
éoliennes également et tintin on a des
hyènes éteinte à cooper et on a des
hyènes est en général en afrique du sud
pendant le pli au pléistocène et
notamment casse ma porte et est ce qui
est une chienne chasseuse c'est à dire
une hyène adaptés à la course
et on n'a également pas qui croque utah
donc qui est la hyène des cavernes
unienne massive exceptionnellement
puissante qui peut exploser et notamment
potentiellement créer des traces de
dents
de taille
très importante
voilà donc ça ça nous permet de
démontrer que à cooper on a pas qu'un
seul événement
d'accumulation on est face à ce qu'on
aime appeler en taphonomie un
palimpseste c'est-à-dire l'accumulation
de différents événements
de dépositions on n'a pas un seul
événement on a ici on efface ici à
un medley de tout ce que peut créer
la taphonomie ce qui résulte en un
assemblage assez complexe à démêler b
pas c'est clair ok
l'ours utilisent des outils comme ça on
arrive très bien à démontrer qu
effectivement
cooper ce n'est pas qu'un simple
one shot
on va passer très vite il faut savoir
qu'on n'a pas que que des carnivores à
coopers on a également une très très
grande diversité de modification de
surface des fossiles notamment par les
insectes et les invertébrés
des petites chambres de pus passion
c'est à dire des trous qui sont créées
par les insectes pour ensuite venir
déposer leurs larves à l'intérieur et
ensuite les larves vont se nourrir et se
servir du calcium de l'os pour former
leur exosquelette et aussi
sur le cadavre pas se nourrir tout
simplement de la chair
on a des petites races également de
mandibules des députés des petits
invertébrés qui vont venir grignoter
l'os lorsqu'ils vont se nourrir sur le
cadavre est encore plus intéressant on a
ici vous voyez sur la figure fdd
microscopique
race un peu aux veaux id allongé comme
ça en piles et bah ça c'est interpréter
ce mot selon moi sur la base
d'observations
exprimer antal moderne et sur la base de
littérature scientifique
j'identifie ça comme étant des
coprolithe d'un siècle c'est-à-dire
du caca fossiles d'insectes tout
simplement
assez
elle à semmar aura observé
on a tout un panel de modification de
surface
d'ordre biologique mais non anthropique
on n'a pas un ben voilà des traces
abrasive plutôt qu' au piétinement des
traces de griottes mans par les rongeurs
dont vous vous souvenez des des vidéos
précédentes caractéristiques sur les
bords saillants d'un os ça va venir
chopper et on va avoir les traces
systématique des double incisive
sa caractéristique des rongeurs et on a
ce qui est marrant sur une des vertèbres
à coopers une banque carrément une
incisive de rongeurs qui est toujours
planté dans la vertèbre
comment c'est possible je ne sais pas
j'imagine que cette petite souris
en voulant se servir de ce bord
saillants de la vertèbre malheureusement
planté son incisif dedans et s'est
retrouvé
sans une de ses incisives ou en tout cas
la casse et une partie et ensuite on a
verni culation c'est-à-dire traces de
deux racines mais également traces de
bactéries
champignons et
lichens
tout ça
on a également des traces anthropique
c'est à dire des traces de boucherie sur
31 reste j'ai observé des traces de
boucherie assez clair assez systématique
là ce n'est pas comme comme le cas de
thika on n'est pas sur un cac qui fait
débat déjà parce qu'on est dans un une
période chronologique beaucoup plus
récente où il est attendu de retrouver
des traces de découpe je vous rappelle
1,4 un million d'années bon bah là la
culture acheuléenne
bien développé homo erectus est là
depuis au minimum 400 mille ans on sait
qu'ils consommer de la viande et qui
pratiquaient en tout cas de la chasse en
tout cas du charognard actifs
on sait qu'ils consommer de la viande on
a des sites plus anciens avec des traces
de découpe
donc c'est attendu de retrouver des
traces de découpe à coopers
on a en plus à cooper spa tout contexte
archéologique qui qui qui est favorable
à la découverte de traces de boucherie
c'est à dire des restes domine et même
si ses parents trompez pas homo erectus
et des outils lithiques car je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle qu'on a
découvert 49 outils lithiques à cooper
et on a un cas assez marrant d'une
phalange d'un bovidé de taille moyenne
avec sur chacune de ses faces
une paire de traces de découpe située au
bord de l'épi fils proximale donc au
bord de l'articulation donc ça c'est
caractéristique de d'une volonté de des
articulations et en particulier d'une
volonté de retirer
les tendons pour pouvoir ensuite
claqué craquer
les phalanges et pouvoir ensuite
retirer la peau de l'animal voilà donc
on arrive aussi à aller au delà de
l'interprétation de la marque de
boucherie et en émettre des hypothèses
sur le geste et sur la fonction de cette
race note la fonction ici
c'est un foot à un fragment de dia fils
du virus
d'un petit pot vite et on a ici des
traces de percussions et traces de
découpe à cnet traces profondes au blick
ça c'est du déchargement c'est à dire
retirer la viande sur le fait sur
l'humérus qui est un os riche en viande
et on va venir ben voilà découper la
viande pour récupérer les meilleurs
morceaux et ensuite pas les traces de
percussion pour en récupérer la moelle
est ici
pour la phalange ça va être des
articulations et
récupération de la peau et d'étangs
d'eau
of monsters and men la galerie des
processus non identifiés pourquoi j'ai
voulu mettre
ça c'est parce qu'il faut également je
trouve que c'est important de dire que
c'est normal peut pas tout savoir même
pour des scientifiques et même si on est
à l'heure actuelle dans une ère de
surspécialisation après notre doctorat
c'est normal de ne pas
tout savoir et de ne pas pouvoir tout
identifier d'une part parce que
votre connaissance notre connaissance
est limité mais également parce que la
connaissance actuelle le paradigme
actuel est limité
comme je voulais si par exemple athlètes
la signature taphonomie des crocodiles
étaient très très peu connu avant dikika
c'est ce qui explique pourquoi personne
n'a jamais parlé des crocodiles
auparavant et que maintenant on se
retrouve à les identifier de plus en
plus dans les registres fossiles
et on n'a pas une connaissance
suffisamment exhaustive nous mêmes et
également la communauté scientifique de
toute la variabilité des processus
taphonomie kba on se retrouve limitée
dans nos interprétations ici c'est le
carat coopers j'ai découvert j'ai fait
face pendant ma thèse à plusieurs
fossiles qui ont des signatures
taphonomie qu juste bizarre quoi et je
n'arrive pas à comprendre quels
processus peut être à l'origine de ce
genre de signature on a par exemple
ce fragment de diaphyse de radius
qui est
je ne sais pas comment le décrire qui
est
complètement
il n'est pas détruit les pas éclaté
il était fort mais c'est pas de la
pathologie ça se voit
c'est d'être assis père profonde de
griffes de morsures
de trace par un objet tranchant je ne
sais pas
extrêmement profond c'est extrêmement
intensif je n'ai jamais vu de processus
taphonomie qu équivalent
dans les expérimentations
[Musique]
ou dans le contexte moderne je ne sais
pas ce qui peut créer
ce processus moi je dirais que
l'hypothèse la plus parcimonieuse ce
serait un carnivore un grand carnivore
plutôt de lord d'une grande yen qui
étaient affamés qui était joueuse à ce
moment là et qui a complètement
surexploités cette hausse
temps un moment deux
de stress alimentaire dans un moment de
pénurie alimentaire je ne sais pas
c'est la seule explication plausible
que j'envisage pour nous j'ai également
un petit à petit un petit éclat au ce
qui a l'impression d'être retouchée ici
c'est à dire de nombreux petits petits
éclats sur la bordure qui va venir créer
cet effet tant clés qu'on pourrait
croire être utilisé comme outil
j'en doute
je pense
à la suite des derniers travaux publiés
sur
l'expérimentation piétinement je pense
que le piétinement peut également créer
ce phénomène de deux micros estimant sur
les bordures des eaux
plein d'autres trucs on a ce
set skis pisar
qui se retrouvent donc pas avec comme
ici
la matière qui a été creusée ici la
matière elle a été
dissoute
à 10 ans très précis
sur des surfaces assez
assez large donc pour moi ça peut pas
être de la dissolution du parrer xemple
à aa2 la digestion parce que la
digestion ça aurait un impact et où l'os
ça aurait pas impacter des autres comme
ça très précise
et pas aussi large
avec un peu de background enfin qu'il
est quelque peu de recherches que j'ai
fait pour ce type de modification
j'ai tendance à penser que certains
gastéropodes donc certains escargots
pourrait créer
ce type de modification en allant sur un
cadavre pour se nourrir
ils peuvent
laisser du sucre
et leur bave à la surface de l'eau ce
qui est extrêmement abrasifs abrasif
parce qu'ils l'utilisent pour digérer
et qui peut
dissoudre et fait recette créé ce genre
de deux dessins
pas je suis pas tout à fait satisfait
avec cette explication mais pourquoi pas
à savoir aussi qu'en afrique il y a
l'escargot géant africain
je vous je vous invite à cliquer sur
youtube si vous si vous ne savez pas ce
que c'est ce sont des gros escargot
thérèse qui peuvent qui sont encore
existant à l'heure actuelle des grands
16 escargots thérèse qui peuvent
faire 30 cm de long jusqu'à un mètre
pour certains individus dont c'était
très très gros escargot et des très très
grosse coquille un des escargots de 1 m
ça fait tout votre bras c'était truc
énorme donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas on
a d'autres comme sa
double desquamation sur un un petit
métacarpe de bovidés qui pourrait faire
appel à cette
cassure par pression
claque comme un bout de poids quoi et
qu'on se retrouve avec cet effet de
desquamation
pourquoi je ne sais pas encore bien
l'expliquer également
et enfin on a également retrouvé un
outil en hausse mais je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail la dent sachez juste
qu'il s'agit d'un fragment
de diaphyse
avec un poli au bout et quand on observe
sous microscope on observe bien
cette micro usures qui est
caractéristique de d'un frottement
systématique
résultant de l'utilisation de cette
offre comme un outil donc vous vous
rendez bien compte qu'on utilise ici
dans une approche taffonneau mik c'est
ça ce qui est important dans l'exemple
de coopers c'est que apple étant donné
qu on n'est pas face à un seul événement
mais a
en fait on étudie un bazar un mix de
plusieurs événements
on doit
obligatoirement faire appel à
différentes sources d'information pour
être capable de tout voir comment tout
s'articule ensemble par exemple pour les
scénarios on peut se permettre de
de rejeter en partie en partie
l'hypothèse d'un aven piège c'est à dire
de d'une accumulation naturelles
notamment parce que ce n'est pas
supportée par les analyses
sédimentologiques ça c'était pas mon
travail ça c'est à l'aide des travail au
dessus des travaux d'autres collègues
de démontrer que la sédimentologie ne
supporte pas vraiment cette hypothèse
mais également parce qu'on a une très
très forte variabilité à la fois dans
les profils de mortalité et dans les
profils de représentation squelettiques
selon les taxes on est selon la taille
des taxons
pourquoi ça permet de rejeter
l'hypothèse d'un aven piège parce que la
veine piège s'il est ouvert r sur
une période de temps suffisamment grande
statistiquement on est en droit de
s'attendre à une strie bution de type
normal de type quotienne pour l'ensemble
des taxes aux et qu'on se retrouve du
coup de fête avec
des signatures taphonomie qu équivalente
entre les actions ici c'est pas le cas
les rongeurs
comme vous l'avez vu 0 04 %
de nos fossiles ont des traces de
rongeurs donc c'est très très peu
on peut se permettre de les mettre de
côté
les hyènes c'est sûr elles ont joué un
rôle pourquoi parce qu'ils font partie
d'une part des carnivores les plus
représentés dans l'assemblage haut ce
que comme vous avez pu le voir on a des
traces à la surface des eaux qui
correspondent en taille de en dimension
à l'impact des hyènes et parce qu'on a
également identifié des cacas fossiles
des coprolithe qui sont attribués à la
hyène brud
les félidés ils sont également
identifiés à cooper notamment parce que
c'est les grands carnivores les plus
représentés du site allez à l'échelle de
la de la famille les félidés sont les
plus représentés
le springbok anti dorcas marsupial hills
c'est le bovidé le plus représenté de
l'assemblage et c'est à l'heure actuelle
la proie préférentiel des léopards où ça
colle plutôt bien avec une activité de
grand félin le profil de mortalité bien
que biaisé par la représentation
squelettiques comme je voulais dit y
colle plutôt bien
à une cuve à une accumulation de félidés
et on a tout un spectre de dimension en
fin de de traces de carnivore qui sont
de dimensions équivalentes à des
carnivores de taille moyenne
c'est-à-dire plutôt ténéo part
les cas l'idée ils sont également
identifiés à cooper notamment parce que
lou poule elle a donc loupé les lacets
le chacal à dos à dos noir donc le
chacal quoi
ils dominent l'assemblage des carnivores
à l'échelle du genre au caniveau du
genre celle où pullella qui est le plus
représenté
et on l'a également identifier à travers
la présence de toutes petites traces
de temps de carnets voir la surface de
certains fossiles et enfin les hominidés
bas ils sont leur activité est également
attestée à 14 d'une part parce que pas
on a des fossiles attribués aux
hominidés un coopers honda des outils en
pierre donc ça nous permet tiens ouais
il était là et ils ont bossé là on a un
outil en hausse a donc ça nous permet
également de dire bah ouais ils
exploitaient les carcasses animales non
pas que pour la viande mais aussi pour
de l'industrie osseuse et enfin ben on a
également les traces de boucherie c'est
à dire les traces de découpe et de
percussions à la surface des eaux donc
ça ça nous permet de bien de démontrer
que l'assemblage de coopers correspond à
un assemblage mixte deux carnivores et
domine et dans les carnivores
d'assemblage mix de différents
événements d une position par les faits
dit et leye d'idées et les qualités
voilà c'est un peu comme ça qu'on fait
de la taphonomie aujourd'hui j'ai un
autre exemple mais il est très long et
très complexe et je pense que j'ai déjà
beaucoup trop parlé donc je verrai avec
julien de la chaîne bat en train de
science
si à l'occasion il me redonne
l'opportunité de prendre la parole
peut-être que je prendrai deux trois
minutes pour vous parler du cas de
rising star se serait peut-être
intéressant de faire une vidéo
entièrement consacré à rising star
pourquoi pas aller sur le site avec
julien et c'est parce que c'était 40 km
d'ici donc pourquoi pas faire un petit
truc mais je vais pas me lancer là ce
soir sur rising star parce que
complexe et c'est encore un débat qui a
lieu à l'heure actuelle
c'est un débat vraiment très très frais
quand je vous dis très très frais c'est
comme c'est comme dikika c'est à dire
qu' il ya des papiers qui sortent tous
les ans
où il parle de la taphonomie de rising
star
extrêmement complexe et un cas complexe
donc on va pas le détailler ici donc on
va rester sur cooper c'est parce que
cooper je pense que c'est une très très
bonne
c'est un très très bon jalons de fin
pour ce cours là pour vous montrer de
comment pratiquer de la taphonomie sur
des sites clio police nationale à
l'heure actuelle je vous ai montré comme
on boit j'ai procédé pendant ma thèse
pour étudier ces 21 il faut s'il est
comment j'ai réussi à
démêler toutes ces informations qui ceux
qui se sont retrouvés
foutez et mixé et
et
peut-être
wef lutter ensemble
comment harry démêler tout cette source
et toute cette complexité je vous ai
montré comment on fait nous à l'heure
actuelle c'est en utilisant plusieurs
méthodes plusieurs approches et
également des informations
provenant de différentes sources de
différents matériels est différent
discipline c'est essentiel donc pour
résumer en termes de conclusion il est
important de rappeler donc que la
taphonomie je vous le rappelle je vous
renvoie aux premières vidéos c'est s'est
littéralement les lois de
l'enfouissement 6 à ce que veut dire est
immo logiquement le terme d'un faux nomi
il est nécessaire lorsqu'on est utile ou
un d'assemblage au ce de prendre
en compte l'ensemble de l'assemblage et
pas seulement quelques pièces un peu
jolie qu'on arrive à identifier
non vous avez pu voir en particulier à
cooper et attica que la plupart des
fossiles qui recèle des informations
taphonomie qu essentiel c'est des
fossiles qu'on n'arrive pas à identifier
ces des fragments parce que il faut bien
se rendre compte que les fossiles les
plus informatif en termes de taf ne vit
pas c'est ce qu'ils ont qui ont subi le
plus c'est ce qui qui recèlent le plus
d'informations c'est ce qu'ils sont qui
ont survécu après avoir subi le plus de
modifications le plus de processus
taphonomie différent c'est eux qui vont
nous nous intéresser donc l'état photo
mist ils sont obligés de s'intéresser
aux fossiles les moins bien conservée
pour avoir une vue exhaustive et
complète de l'assemblage aussi
comme je voulais dire une approche
interdisciplinaire intra disciplinaire
est essentielle en taxonomie je
discutais avec
pas avec christine steiniger d'ailleurs
celle qui a fouillé cooper skies je
discutais avec elle hier et elle me
disait c'est assez intéressant
elle me dit m et par deux d'une lecture
qu'elle a faits récemment sur ce terme
un peu de nouveau
donc vous savez on a interdit si pline
aires intra disciplinaire multi si plein
air on est un peu de mal à faire la
différence entre tous ces thèmes et bien
maintenant on m a fait part d'un nouveau
terme qui serait anti disciplinaire
j'ai pas encore eu trop le temps de
penser à ça et d'essayer de le digérer
et de l'appliquer à mon propre travail
et aussi parce que le bas j'ai pas fait
de la recherche encore mais
peut-être que mon approche et la proche
d'autres chercheurs en taphonomie est
plus de l'ordre de lentilles
disciplinaire que de l'inter ou du multi
disciplinaire parce qu'on fait appel à
tellement de disciplines
différentes qui sont toutes tellement
interconnecté qu'il n'est plus possible
de les délimiter donc on n'est même plus
dans l'ordre du disciplinaire on est de
les revendre en lentilles disciplinaire
parce que tout est connecté en
taphonomie
vote mettrie votre vote matrice
sédimentaires votre anatomie
vous pouvez utiliser aussi
la topographie de votre site
utilisé des données d'observation et aux
logiques et écologique dans des parcs
naturels moderne vous pouvez utiliser
des données comme on l'a vu pour lucie
de de médecine légale qui proviennent
d'études de patients à l'heure actuelle
des cabots terne
tout à la paléontologie de l'archéologie
bref tous alliés ensemble peut-être
qu'il faudrait à l'avenir que je change
mon cours que je le corrige et que je
pars interdisciplinaire pour aller faire
de l'anti disciplinaire je ne sais pas
encore
de tous façon le cours est toujours en
construction
la taphonomie également passage départ
était de vous le dire à l'heure actuelle
et au plein milieu des débats
scientifiques actuelles ce soit en
termes des cui finalité de l'origine de
des comportements sociaux complexes
comme la chasse et le charognard le
partage
de nourriture le partage des ressources
et des étés tâche
mais également dans le débat chasse vers
ce charognard
mais également sur la corrélation avec
l'encéphale isation au cours de
l'évolution de la ligne mais bref
et de certains comportements comme on
l'a vu assez complexe comme
cannibalisme cannibalisme rituel et
c'est donc la taphonomie elle est au
coeur de ces débats à l'heure actuelle
il ya des papiers qui sont publiés tous
les ans encore pour parler de ça donc
c'est essentiel
et il reste encore tellement à faire la
taphonomie
c'est une discipline qui est extrêmement
active en ce moment
énormément de nouveau de nouvel
équipement sont appliquées tous les ans
à la taphonomie de nouvelles approches
statistiques
voilà c'est assez incroyable c'est assez
stimulant de travailler dans cette
discipline parce que comme vous l'avez
vu ces disciplines qui fait appel aux
sciences naturelles en général
et qui fait appel à énormément de
discipline d'équipements et de méthodes
différentes
vous pouvez si vous aimez les sciences
naturelles la taphonomie est vraiment au
centre de toutes ces sciences naturelles
ça va de votre climat de votre
environnement de votre anatomie
de votre contexte sédimentaires de votre
topographie faute géologie tout ça ça a
un impact sur votre iphone au mit et
c'est ça qui est intéressant ça rend
la recherche et la discipline
extrêmement complexe vais tellement
passionnant donc voilà c'est super
voilà où ça j'en ai pas trop parler donc
je vais pas
je ne vais pas cistella dessus
voilà un peu 3 donc si vous êtes resté
jusque là vous avez vu toutes les vidéos
tous les cours et ses félicitations
je pense que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
parlé si vous êtes arrivé jusque là je
pense que c'est parce que vous êtes un
minimum intéressé parce que par ses
disciples et si vous l'êtes et et vous
avez un peu envie d'aller plus loin je
vous conseille la lecture de ces trois
ouvrages
un peu technique un peu exhaustif mais
si je vous dis si je devrais si je
devais vous en conseiller qu'un seul ce
serait le premier celui de charles bob
brain 1980 enter the haunted
c'est la pierre angulaire de la
taphonomie plie au pléistocène
ce travail est une est un chef-d'oeuvre
donc je vous le conseille les deux
autres sont un peu plus technique un peu
plus universitaire donc c'est pour ceux
qui veulent aller un peu plus loin c'est
un peu plus technique voilà en tout cas
vous avez mon adresse mail si jamais
vous avez des questions pour quoi que ce
soit je reste à votre disposition
je remercie encore julien de la chaîne
entracte saillants de entre axians de de
m'avoir donné l'opportunité de diffuser
montcourt est ma passion à travers sa
chaîne et et voilà donc merci à tous et
à bientôt j'espère peut-être pour un
nouveau coup rude
une nouvelle vidéo